some things are best kept contained
after all this is the founding principle
behind the scp foundation themselves to
secure and contain the most dangerous
anomalies in order to protect human
lives but within the foundation itself
are things which should never be
uncovered secrets that must never be
told secured behind multiple layers of
containment like the seven seals of
revelation is a threat so high level in
its nature that it can't even be given a
class scp-5999
but in order to truly understand this
late series scp we have to go all the
way back to one of the earliest anyone
looking for scp-001 will quickly realize
that there are several different
entities and anomalies that share this
designation many reasons have been given
for this classification quirk perhaps
they were all discovered in the early
days of the foundation before the
current numbering system was introduced
others have suggested that many
different
scp-001s are an intentional misdirection
by the foundation to keep the nature of
the true first scp a closely guarded
secret one of the many entities and the
one we'll be referring to as scp-001 to
understand
scp-5999 is otherwise known as the
database information about the databases
kept a secret to the entire scp
foundation apart from the overseer
council the reason behind this well that
would be because this scp-001
contains details of the very nature of
the foundation itself including its
creation not how the organization was
founded mind you how it was created and
by whom we're about to break the most
powerful layer of containment of all the
fourth wall you see to you or i the scp
foundation and its vast catalog of user
generated articles on the creative and
the creepy are nothing more than a
source of entertainment it can be fun to
study the lore and the nuances of
different scps appreciating the
imagination and hard work that the
authors put into writing them it can
even inspire us fuel our own written
endeavors whether that takes the form of
fan fiction independent stories original
scps or even a youtube series but when
all is said and done we all know that
the scp foundation is fictional and they
know it too pieced together from various
fragments of information within their
own archives the database contains
everything the foundation knows about
the real world authors of the scp wiki
just like we told you it's time to weigh
a fond farewell to the fourth wall the
metaphorical barrier that separates what
we know to be real from what we know to
be purely fiction the fact that they
exist in this fictional capacity is
something the overseer council hopes to
hide from the rest of the foundation's
personnel but they also have plans in
mind for the scp wiki writers
responsible for creating them and
expanding the roster of anomalies they
keep contain the scp wiki entry on
scp-001 the database closes with a
proposal a plan from the o5 council to
reach the wiki's authors in the real
world through memetic kill agents that
will put them to sleep and then kill
them with that important background
context in mind now let's go all the way
back to the other end of the scp wiki
and take a look at scp-5999
when first accessing the file you the
reader will notice a few format
differences between this entry and
others within the scp archive each
section of
scp-5999 is hidden behind an encryption
and accessing these will reveal the
different levels of this entry remember
how we mentioned the seven seals of
revelation at the start of this video
that wasn't a coincidence in the bible's
book of revelation there are seven
symbolic seals securing a book that john
of patamos saw in his vision of the
apocalypse when these seven seals are
broken and the book is opened this
symbolizes the second coming of the
messiah and marks the beginning of the
biblical apocalypse in much the same
vein scp-5999
is sealed in seven different parts each
behind its own encryption culminating in
one apocalyptic ending so at this point
you're probably thinking what actually
is
scp-5999 what could be so dangerous that
it has to stay hidden in multiple
segments
well on the surface
scp-5999 is just a story it details one
of the scp foundation's many
investigations into an anomalous object
nothing too strange about that but
there's something more to it since with
the foundation there always is and it
has something to do with the images at
the header of each section of the entity
at the top of each part of scp-5999
is a picture of a group of candles seven
to be exact but the further down you
read one by one the candles start to go
out until you reach the end of scp-5999
delving into the first of these sections
the
entry describes a corpse that seems to
be cursed with multiple anomalous
properties after the assault and murder
of one miss jacqueline hallcroft her
remains were scattered according to this
entry any person coming into contact
with a part of miss holcroft's deceased
body or anyone who learns about what
caused her death will experience
anomalous effects these manifest in
various ways for example subjects may
hallucinate that they see a disheveled
woman with wounds similar to miss
holcroft's before her dismemberment this
site is sometimes accompanied by sounds
of whispering and even begging that
calls the subject seeing and hearing
things by their name others have
reported hearing an unknown song set to
the tune of twinkle twinkle little star
the anomalous influence of miss
holcroft's dismembered remains is known
to continue until a subject's death with
many reporting seeing the woman's
deceased body lurking in their old
photos or suffering sleep paralysis as
they feel something being forcibly
removed from their guts some subjects
even report discovering body parts and
organs anything from fingers to eyes to
teeth to hair and finding it at random
places such as when opening a drawer or
in their food finally a number of
subjects affected by the remains of miss
holcroft have reported a specific
irrational fear the fear that the chains
are weakening even after the foundation
recovered jacqueline holcroft's bones
and her remains were buried in a proper
funeral the effects that her dead body
parts had over living subjects did not
stop subjects reported their children
went missing and the attendees at miss
holcroft's funeral were somehow
spontaneously disemboweled after the
ceremony to keep these effects to a
minimum the foundation apparently has a
containment procedure in place the
scp-5999 entry details something called
procedure seven-fold wherein the scp
foundation gathers seven civilians and
brings them to a location called
albright manor on october 30th these
seven people are sedated and awake on
the night of october 31st all entrances
to albright manor are sealed trapping
the civilians inside observe via network
of surveillance devices throughout the
manner procedure seven fold always
results in the deaths of the seven
civilian witnesses brought in by the
foundation whether they are told to
perform a ritual or offered as a
sacrifice is unclear the following
morning foundation cleanup crews will
remove the remains of these people
disposing of their bodies with an
incinerator for the rest of the year
until procedure sevenfold needs to be
conducted again foundation personnel on
site at albright manor are instructed to
be careful around any surfaces that
contain the phrase
this is where i died by now you are most
likely wondering what the remains of
miss holcroft and procedure sevenfold
have to do with anything we've talked
about so far what is the connection to
scp-001 the database is there something
linking an anomalous corpse with the
foundation's knowledge of its own
fictional existence what does a fear of
the chain's weakening mean and why do
none of these questions seem to
acknowledge what those seven candles
represent or why they're still gradually
going out scrolling further through
scp-5999 doesn't seem to yield many more
answers though in fact the more of the
sections you look into the less it seems
to be about miss holcroft or even make
any link to the database and the deeper
you go the fewer candles remain lit the
next few portions of the
scp-5999 entry are dedicated to
completely different investigations that
have little to nothing to do with
procedure sevenfold ms holcroft's corpse
and the anomalous effects it creates are
also absent in later segments of this
entry in the scp archive so if the
cursed body parts of jacqueline holcroft
are not
scp-5999 then what is one report details
the fates of a mobile task force trapped
in a fog shrouded town here they
encounter a lamb that appears to be
undead and evolves into an ungodly
winged beast before the mtf team's very
eyes another that follows is a
transcript of an exorcism during a
classified foundation operation
one agent grace was possessed by a
demonic entity and sent to the
department of demonology specialist in
demonic psychology dr peter mcneal
attempted to remove the demon inhabiting
agent grace however after trying to
intimidate the demonic entity with
various passages from biblical texts it
appears as though maybe the demon was
able to spread its influence to both
agent grace and dr mcneil of course
neither of these reports seemed to
answer any of the pressing questions or
explain the exact nature of scp-5999
as you go further into the entry you
can't help but notice how often chains
are referenced in fact that seems to be
the only thing constant in all these
disjointed segments mentions of a
failure of the chains to hold what lies
beneath and chains that have become too
few in number to hold it all create the
sense that something once was locked up
sealed securely away is managing to
break free then finally as the last
candle goes out you are literally
brought face to face with the horror of
scp-5999 and its true nature is revealed
to you a decaying desiccated corpse
stares out of the screen at you its eyes
are sunken deep into its skull lips
shriveled almost completely away
exposing rows of rotten teeth could it
be miss holcroft's body you aren't sure
what you are sure of is the corpse's
face is getting closer to the screen and
now it's smiling at you you can feel
your heart pounding beating against your
rib cage as the world around you begins
to fade and your life slips away from
you the last thing you see is the grim
face of the corpse staring out at you
with its dead sunken eyes the truth of
scp-5999 is that it has been
specifically designed to kill whoever
reads it by whom you may be asking by
the scp foundation themselves cast your
mind back to the database and remember
that the overseer council are aware of
their own fictional existence they know
that they aren't real and plan to use
him a meta kill agent to take out the
scp wiki authors that created them
scp-5999 is that kill agent an entity
created by fiction to kill those living
in reality
scp-5999 works by drawing a person in
offering disjointed and disconnected
horror stories as a means of grabbing a
reader's attention further and further
down through the entry that person will
go searching for the meaning behind
these chilling tails and therein lies
the trap each layer each section of
scp-5999 that you read is another candle
extinguished and with every flame that
goes out a seal is broken a chain
becomes unbound allowing the entity
contained within the archive and tree
itself to get closer its sole purpose is
to fulfill the proposal laid out by the
o5 council after learning that they were
fictional along with the entire scp
universe by pulling you in with the
mystery and intrigue of the confusing
convoluted stories
scp-5999 is able to deploy jumping out
of the screen towards you condemning you
to a dark and grisly fate or maybe
that's just what the o5 council and the
scp foundation wants us to think either
way it might just be safer to get your
scp knowledge here at scp explained and
speaking of go check out
scp-1730 what happened to site 13 the
full story compilation and
scp-5545 mysterious tunnels in
antarctica abnormality for more
terrifying tales but at least these ones
won't kill you probably